il se mit great pleasure tu ne vas être
plus de barack obama
tu te levada sexting non seulement c'est
peut-être un discours très attendu du
44e président des états unis pour
marquer le 100e anniversaire de
naissance du prix nobel de la paix
nelson mandela
fidèle à ses habitudes oratoire barack
obama a ouvert son allocution avec une
touche d'autodérision mais l'humour a
vite fait place aux thèmes chers du
leader sud africain les droits de la
personne de féminisme la lutte contre le
racisme et la liberté sauf chez nous si
nous voulons suivre les traces de madiba
nous devons travailler plus fort être
plus intelligent et apprendre des
erreurs récentes dans son allocution de
plus d'une heure barack obama a
multiplié les attaques à mots à peine
couverts contre son successeur dans
notre homme il s'en est pris à ses
politiques d'immigration qui alimente le
racisme à son opinion climato-sceptiques
et à sa facilité de mentir
joubouri de tête
il faut croire aux faits sans les faits
il n'y a plus moyen de coopérer et si je
dis ceci est un podium
vous dites non c'est un éléphant ce sera
bien difficile pour nous de s'entendre
barack obama a aussi décoché des flèches
à l'endroit des leaders autocratiques
qui utilisent les médias pour promouvoir
la peur et la rancune proches ont noté
la presse libre est attaqué la censure
s'accroît et les médias sociaux
deviennent des outils de promotion de la
haine et de la propagande
ce plaidoyer de barack obama pour la
liberté la démocratie survient
coincidence ou non au lendemain du
sommet 30 poutine qui a fait beaucoup de
vagues
partout dans le monde je voulais mettre
savez ici couture radio canada montréal